Колись за часів соціалістичної Німецької Демократичної Республіки
в цьому лісі проживала партійна еліта: очільник НДР Еріх Гонекер
та міністр держбезпеки Еріх Мільке мали в цьому лісовому
поселені свої резиденції.
Сьогодні ж вхід сюди відкритий. Тут працює клініка,
де пацієнти проходять реабілітацію і нині проживають українці.
Вони опинилися тут через війну, а житло їм надала клініка.
Утім, деякі українці знайшли в цій клініці не тільки прихисток, а й роботу.
Клініка Берлін-Бранденбург стала, мабуть, одним з найбільших
роботодавців для українських біженців у Німеччині.
Тут працевлаштували аж сорок втікачів від війни в Україні.
Працювати українським біженцям тут вигідніше, аніж лише
отримувати соціальні виплати від держави.
Серед тих, хто знайшов тут роботу, - Лариса Горай.
Разом із сином вона поселилася в одному з корпусів на території
клініки в березні 2022 року. А вже через місяць почала
працювати у кафетерії лікарні - без знання німецької мови.
Спочатку, знаєте, було дуже тяжко.
Тому що, коли нам запропонували за контрактом тут працювати,
ми були здивовані, адже ти ще не знаєш мови!
Але попри це нам запропонували і сказали, що в процесі роботи
все одно автоматично набагато швидше вивчаєш мову,
ніж коли просто ходиш на інтеграційні курси.
Хоча вони у будь-якому разі потрібні та необхідні.
Ми отримуємо їжу в таких боксах. Ми спускаємося вниз на кухню.
Внизу в нас основна кухня для всіх 4-х поверхів.
У цих боксах нам видають їжу на кожен поверх.
Спочатку були, звісно, страх, паніка. Ти дивишся на індивідуальні картки
пацієнтів і нічого не розумієш…
Німці дуже пунктуальні люди. Чітко за часом, якщо вечеря
о п'ятій годині вечора, то о 17:00 чітко має бути все накрито,
все засервіровано ідеально.
У Києві жінка мала невеликий манікюрний салон.
Працювати в кафетерії для неї - новий досвід.
Лариса каже, що за півтора року змогла заговорити німецькою
саме завдяки роботі з людьми.
Для мене це великий досвід у житті. Щодо роботи - мені подобається.
Спочатку був страх: як я з цим впораюся?
А зараз для мене - це наче моє. Почуваюся у своїй тарілці.
У нас учора чоловік заїхав 1929 року народження. Йому 94 роки.
Я підбираю їм естраду 60-х, 70-х, на телефоні вмикаю…
А вони… З таким задоволенням смакують, їдять, взагалі просто…
Наче дрібниця, здається. А ще я їм вмикаю італійську естраду.
То їх потім спробуй попросити, щоб вони пішли. Але ж задоволені!
Бранденбурзький реабілітаційний центр почав приймати українських біженців
одразу на початку російського вторгнення в Україну.
Тоді тут поселилося близько двохсот українців.
Клініка одразу запропонувала їм роботу і паралельно вчити мову на курсах.
Спочатку українців працевлаштовували терміном на рік,
але декому вже навіть вдалося отримати постійний контракт.
Важливою ланкою у комунікації між керівництвом та українськими
біженцями стала Оксана Жолудь. Так само, як і інші українські біженці
від війни, вона опинилися в гуртожитку клініки навесні минулого року.
Одразу після приїзду - спочатку на волонтерських засадах,
а потім з офіційним контрактом - вона почала перекладати з англійської
інформацію від керівництва реабілітаційного центру для українців.
Зокрема і про наявні вакансії.
Ми цю інформацію доносили до людей, що є такі і такі вакансії,
в таких-то секторах. Усі зацікавлені можуть залишити свої координати,
з вами потім зв'яжуться…
Керівництво клініки Бранденбург було зацікавлене допомогти.
І допомогти з працевлаштуванням також.
Тобто всі охочі, які хотіли знайти роботу, в принципі її знайшли.
У різних секторах, звичайно, але вони її знайшли.
Спочатку всіх взяли без знання мови, але до всіх була умова,
що вони мають відвідувати німецькі курси для того, щоб собі ж
у першу чергу полегшити життя. Дуже складно працювати,
якщо ти не розумієш, що відбувається.
Оксана теж почала вчити німецьку з нуля.
Каже, що англійської мови, яку вона знала до переїзду в Німеччину,
вистачало лише на початку роботи.
Через півтора року роботи Оксана вже отримала необмежений
у часі робочий контракт.
Жінка стала тим ланцюгом, який забезпечує зв'язок
між адміністрацією клініки і українцями: вона вирішує питання,
пов'язані з біженцями і працевлаштованими в клініці
українцями. За словами Оксани, її робота триває, по суті, 24 на 7.
Фактично мій робочий день триває 24 години.
Він починається фактично о 5 ранку, тому що я маю відвести сина в садочок.
Але все одно мій мобільний телефон є у всіх.
Тому якщо у когось щось трапляється вночі, то в принципі
я отримую якесь повідомлення або дзвінок.
Що це за питання? Це все: починаючи із заповнення якихось заявок,
закінчуючи розбором пошти.
Реабілітаційний центр запропонував українцям різні вакансії.
Клініці насамперед були потрібні люди, які допомагають
подавати обіди пацієнтам, а також у галузі прибирання та садівництва.
Доглядальниками за пацієнтами українці тут не працюють,
адже для цього необхідно зробити так званий Ausbildung -
пройти спеціальні профкурси. Українці задіяні тут лише як помічники.
Ідеться про мінімальну допомогу у догляді,
як-от прогулятися з пацієнтами, якщо їм потрібна допомога з пересуванням.
Або нагляд за пацієнтами, які втратили пам'ять, аби ті залишалися
на території клініки під час прогулянок.
Деякі українські біженці працюють на рецепції.
Анастасія Сичева з Дніпра працює у відділі неврології.
Я одразу була готова до того, що хочу вийти на роботу.
Я вже досить добре розумію, що мені кажуть, я впораюся.
Раніше Анастасія працювала в супермаркеті.
Німецьку вона вчила в українській школі, але каже, що заговорити
змогла лише, коли закінчила інтеграційний курс тут, у Німеччині.
У нашому чаті клініки Бранденбург написали,
що сюди потрібен рецепціоніст. Я якраз їхала на мовні курси у потязі.
Я одразу подумала, що треба написати.
Тепер серед основних завдань Анастасії - зустрічати
нових пацієнтів і показувати їм палати.
Найперше я приходжу і розкладаю газети.
Наші пацієнти дуже люблять читати.
Включаю комп'ютер і дивлюся, скільки нових пацієнтів надійде.
Записую, щоб, коли вони приїдуть, я знала,
куди мені треба провести пацієнтів.
За словами Анастасії, вона чудово розуміється з пацієнтами
і відвідувачами клініки.
З деякими пацієнтами в неї навіть зав'язалися приязні дружні стосунки.
Я, можливо, не можу відразу відповісти, але дуже добре
розумію все, що мені кажуть.
Син Анастасії навчається в спортивній школі.
Тринадцятирічний хлопець - футболіст і проживає в спортивному інтернаті
у Франкфурті-на-Одері. На вихідних він приїжджає до батьків.
Анастасія з чоловіком нещодавно також переїхали з гуртожитку
в окреме житло. Робота їй подобається,
і шукати нову жінка поки не планує.
Мені ця робота дуже подобається.
Я хотіла би далі вивчати німецьку мову, бо, можливо,
хотіла би пройти профкурси.
Я ще не знаю, які плани, бо дуже складна ситуація,
але ми плануємо із сім'єю залишитися тут, у Німеччині.
Як і Анастасія, майже всі українці, яких працевлаштувала клініка,
працюють не за фахом.
Це бухгалтери. Це люди навіть з юридичною освітою,
з економічною освітою. Це люди взагалі з дуже різних галузей.
Є ті, в кого є вища освіта, в когось середня…
Але все одно всі ці люди в основному працюють не за фахом.
Та і сама Оксана, журналістка за освітою, працює не за фахом -
у секретаріаті клініки. А також секретарем у школі
на базі клініки, де на медсестер і доглядальників вчаться
люди різних національностей. Ця школа знаходиться у приміщенні,
добре знайомому Оксані. Адже саме тут вона разом
з п'ятирічним сином провела перші місяці свого перебування в Німеччині.
Ось тут кімната, в якій я проживала.
Перші шість місяців, коли я приїхала, я проживала в цій кімнаті.
Тоді у цьому гуртожитку заселили понад сто тридцять українців.
Нині залишаються лише близько п'ятдесяти.
Працевлаштованим у клініці українцям з пошуком житла допоміг роботодавець.
Хтось, як Оксана, переїхав з гуртожитку в квартири в містечку Бернау,
хтось - у будиночки і кімнати в корпусах на території самої клініки.
Житло працевлаштовані в клініці українці оплачують самі із зарплатні.
Через рік після переїзду до Німеччини до Оксани приїхала її мама.
Пані Надія - колишня продавчиня. Сьогодні вона, як і донька,
також працює в клініці - у кафетерії для пацієнтів.
Я що в Україні працювала, що тут буду працювати.
Скучаю... У мене син залишився в Україні.
Таке життя... Дуже важке для України. Але ми пам'ятаємо.
Не знаю, як усі, але українці хочуть повернутися в Україну.
Так.. Обов'язково…
Так багато рідних лишилися в Україні.
Така доля, розкидала всіх по Європі й Америці.
Дуже сподіваюся, що скоро все закінчиться. І ми повернемося.
Якби роботи не було, я би не витримала.
Робота настільки емоційно заспокоює.
Ти в русі, ти в роботі, ти забуваєш…
Пані Лариса, яка теж працює в кафетерії, також мріє повернутися додому.
Там на неї чекає старший син.
Я вже давно повернулася б!
Якби не старший син… Він у мене військовий…
Йому післязавтра, до речі, буде лише 22.
Знаєте, він як військова людина каже:
"Мамо, коли я дам команду, тоді повертатиметеся".
А наразі, оскільки він любить свого молодшого брата, каже:
"Поки що з малим вивчайте німецьку мову.
І тіште мене тим, що живете там, де нема сирен і вибухів".
Тому якось так…